hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
today we're going to talk about the ps
audio power plant uh oh sorry
inside chuck
now we're gonna talk about the new uh
product the uh topping dx5 which was
released yesterday
it's a combination dac and balance stack
and headphone amplifier
it costs about 449 dollars which may
sound high but remember the uh
terrible problems industry has with
supply chain and
skyrocketing uh costs of components
the device looks very different than
previous topping products if you've seen
them um you know they used to have this
machined aluminum
squarish kind of design now they've come
to this oval shape
um let me get the unit for you so you
can have a better look at it um it's got
a large oled display as you can see um
this is sort of the overall
sort of roundish uh enclosure that it
comes in
uh i really like the uh look of the the
feel of the volume control is one of the
best i've felt as far as how responsive
it is and
it accelerates to what you want it to
accelerate based on you know how fast
you crank it and it's just a delight to
use
in front you see that it has a quarter
inch headphone jack and an xlr which
typically would be a balanced connection
with four times the uh output voltage
but that's not the case here these two
are identical so it's a nice convenience
if you get a headphone that comes with
only uh balanced uh input
then you can use this without having to
go buy an adapter
looking at the back
you'll see that it has uh one of my
favorite features which is a
built-in power supply so you just plug
in an ac cord into it rather than having
a dongle that's separate and takes up
space in uh
your power strip uh nice on off switch
so you can permanently shut it off
uh you have the usual connections which
is so
balanced xlr output these are true
balanced and then you also have rca out
there's a standard connection for a
bluetooth antenna
toslink optical
over here and usb and this is also for
coax input which i did not test
one note is a lot of manufacturers have
come up with these covers for these rcas
but they're painted neck to get off many
of them i have to use a tool toppings
gone to these rubber ones they're
actually quite nice as far as being able
to pull out put back in and because
they're squishy you can grab them with
your nail and and pull them out
anyway let's go back to the uh to the uh
written review and you can see the
picture over here
but the display is oled then there
people complain about the
longevity of that it has an auto off for
the display and you can set its
brightness
so that should mitigate it uh what it
does long term i don't know
but i do like the big volume control in
the middle which many of their
competitors forget and they put the
sample rate in here in large letters and
then they put the volume in small
letters which is uh
silly you know volume control is what
you use
sampling rate is just the convenience
anyway uh let's jump into measurements
and see if we have the usual topping
product and indeed we do using the xlr
connections uh we get a synapse which is
a ratio of these distortion spikes plus
noise relative to our signal
and we see that it gets a sign out of
about 122 db
uh what does that mean if you rank them
within almost 400 dags that i've tested
it lands at number four over here
which is uh incredible as far as
accomplishment look at what separates
that the top 20. the worst one in top
20s got a size of 120 db and the best
one is 123. so it's only three db
separating the top 20 from each other
worse the best so
try to squeeze in in here this level
requires incredible amount of
optimization
of noise and distortion to try to land
in here
um actually i was going to give you a
little bit of an introduction i forgot
you're probably bewildered like i am as
first number of new dac introductions
from topping on and their competitors
um the reason for that partially is that
the industries when i started back in
2000 uh 2019 measuring stuff was
predominantly based on dax ships from
company called ess
and
then a shift migration happened to a
japanese company called akm and
companies like topping went through
almost replacing every dac they had with
akm
no sooner than they've done that and
the competitors done the same thing akm
had an unfortunate factory at their
semiconductor fab facility
and production stopped overnight so
every one of them has had to go back and
swa build a new design it's not an easy
thing you don't think i want you to put
the other one in they're very very
different chips and the surrounding
circuits all have after we don't
and they've all have to do that in a
hurry because otherwise you couldn't
sell any product so they've gone back
and
rebuilt them all on on ess
dac chips and and this is also on the
stack
conversion so that partially explains it
but then again also just the furious
pace uh at which these companies uh
produce product is just incredible uh
you know most companies couldn't produce
one product more than a year or two and
they're able to spit out a new uh
component every two or three months so
it's amazing speed and efficiency to
have and they don't cut quality
obviously as you can see from
measurements some of you use rca output
not xlr i highly recommend that you
shift over to xlr because
the noise immunity
from ground loops is just fantastic with
xlr and whenever you involve a pc it's
got its own power supply you got a dac
it's got its own power supply power
cords
connected different spots and you get
these uh the the two grounds wind up
being slightly out of whack and then the
current flows and that current is 60
hertz and harmonics so you hear hum and
buzz
whenever you have ground loops and once
you have a ground loop that painted a
neck to get rid of you may have to
switch to toss link which has its own
limitations as well as
sample rates and stuff
and it's just no good solution so take
advantage of these low you know
reasonably priced uh balanced dax if
you're gonna hook them up to power
monitor especially the power monitor has
its own ac outlet and its own potential
for ground loop and so if you can at all
get a
dac when use is bounced up but if for
now you only have rca and you want to
hook that up to your system of course
the topping dx5 has rca output and you
almost give up nothing in performance
cyanide drops one or two d visa it's
still quite reasonable
and that drop mainly comes from
increased noise
because the signal swing
is two volts versus four volts and that
costs you
on this because the maximum signal has
dropped
so the residual
noise becomes a larger portion of it
when you use rca so you lose about 3 db
of of quietness
linearity test is just walking the park
is you don't see the speed of this
running but whenever there's noise in
here the analyzer runs very slow
scrolling through trying to get these
sample points but when there's no noise
it just goes
right through it and that's what topping
the x5 did and it's just extremely good
this limit is 20 bits 120 db uh what
this says is that it's probably linear
to 130 db or even better so it goes way
out there
um
the intermodulation test is a test of 60
hertz and seven kilohertz simultaneously
being sent to the uh dac with a four to
one ratio so it is testing both low
frequency and high frequency noise and
and distortion at the same time the
performance starts off extremely good
beating its own
product topping dx3 pro which was one of
my favorites three years ago and many
dax failed to do better than that uh
believe it or not of course it handle it
beats that then it gets this classic
problem we get with ess stack chips in
that they uh all of a sudden there's a
new distortion mechanism that kicks in
in these
mid levels
we were the first ones to discover this
i remember getting a new topping deck
and noticing that compared to his
previous generation had this hump so i
called it essimd hump and the phrases
caught on we had to live with that for a
couple years until
companies start to figure and figure out
how to eliminate them topping was the
first one that did that and then others
followed gradually so it's strange to
see it in here but i read that they're
going to send out a firmware update
to fix this the reason you can fix
infirmary in that ess has a distortion
compensation
logic where you can
in a way control the linearity of the
dac through just programming registers
it's tricky in that you have to optimize
them there can be side effects in in
doing that
so it's a rare miss by topping to catch
this in in
before release but then again the
firmware update is going to be there and
it's fixed then what you buy
will be reflected of this i got this
unit a while back and they had to
embargo as far as releasing the
measurements till yesterday so likely
what you get will have that fixed once i
get my hands on it i'll i'll verify that
but for now it does have this but the
performance is so good even when it has
this hump it basically matches the dx3
pro so
it's this extreme low noise that it has
that allows you to see this if it's
noise level was up here like tapping and
dx3 pro you wouldn't even see the hump
so in a way how good it is
in noise level makes that problem stand
out and that's one thing by the way i
hate about ess at a company you know
i've tried to contact them multiple
times they won't even answer my emails
pleaded with them to solve this problem
and then get all of their
people who are designing around their
chip to have to know what to do and how
to solve it they haven't lifted a finger
to do that and left their uh
all these other companies to figure it
out one by one and while in this domain
people have have figured out i sometimes
test uh you know professional audio
interfaces with this hump in them and
really bad ones because they haven't
measured they haven't seen it and they
didn't know about any fix they should
have
come up with their own fix and reference
design and communicated it to the uh
you know design ones that they have uh
for that reason i really like akm
because it didn't through this problem
you know this is basically a design flaw
as far as i'm concerned in ess tax uh
what leads to it it's an unknown why it
does that but it's it's a peculiar thing
and maybe that's where they want to keep
it hidden
anyway by the way i heard red i think
that they came factory is coming online
now and so maybe it will be a
switch back to akm future products i
don't know uh but that certainly will be
fine with me
um jitter test on usb is almost perfect
uh we basically you want to see noise
floor that this low basically goes on
there's a local audience review and then
these three spikes in here there's one
in here that shouldn't be there and it's
a power supply component
it's very very low noise
um but i think it that interferes with
the main signal and causes two little
sidebands over here you know you can't
see them because they're hugging this
so
there's a bit of jitter but it's just
incredibly low level we're talking minus
140 minus 150
so
no way is it audible or
anything but i'm so spoiled with
perfection out of topping that uh i'm
forced to point out these little
niggling things
but this one is not as niggling in that
when i
use toslink as the input i see these uh
tall jitter components at least they
look like jitter although the height is
not the same
and um these other uh and then this one
over here
it's common to see wars performance and
toslink and coax these days
uh most of us don't use them
or if you use them it's not for critical
use it's from your tv sound or what have
you and these are well below audibility
we're talking the worst case one is
below minus 120 db your threshold of
hearing is minus 115.
it just
it's impossible to make a case that this
is a real audible problem but
you know we expect perfection from
topping and uh i expected to see you
know jitter components down here but not
too tall ones like this
anyway
um multi-tone we you know a lot of the
tests you've seen so far have been
you know fixed 102 tones then i run a
multi-tone test where there's 32 signals
you can see them all over here spread
like this
from 20 to 20 kilohertz
and
the thing we look at is down here we
call this grass which is all these
intermodulation distortion products or
noise
and you can see it basically obscures
everything below this level that levels
minus 130 db if you divide that by 6 you
get 22 bits of distortion free range
which is superb basically it's as
transparent as you can get
on this so that's why it did so well in
the cyanide score
unlike some of the other ess decks that
have you know seven or eight uh filters
there are three to choose from and
that's fine by me one is a sharp one
here which is uh pretty good this this
green one is filter number three it's
called mode three on it and
the default is this purple one which is
those classic slower ones that you get
uh in dax these days and then a wider
band one over here that sorry the
classic one is this red one and then you
got this filter one the red one is the
default filter which is pretty typical
one in in dac chips
so you have a choice which one to use
all of them have a flat audible response
uh to 20 kilohertz or so so this one
maybe sacrifices the hair uh on this
thing so you get to choose i don't think
you'll hear a difference between them
but if you want to play with your deck
you can
um
one thing we're doing different in this
test is that we're trying to measure
distortion all the way up to 20
kilohertz uh to see harmonics at 20
kilos we need to measure 40 kilohertz
and and 60 kilohertz and 80 kilohertz so
for that i measure this this
sweep i measure up to 90 kilohertz
bandwidth so way above audible band and
the sampling rate of the
content is 48 kilohertz and
you can see how beautiful this graph is
it's very hard to get down here this is
a reference here uh board that i tested
for four years ago three years ago uh
many dacs especially high index are way
up here uh on avr's and what have you
getting down here is just you know very
very difficult it shows you not only is
the spectrum clean in the audible band
but it's also a clean and ultrasonic
band because every one of these
measurements these higher up ones is
influenced by what is out here because
it sums them all up to 90 kilos
bandwidth
okay so this is a dac portion extremely
good performance with couple of notable
issues that uh talked about
um
a lot of people use in-ear monitors for
uh listening to uh
music
i use them in
summertime when these headphones get too
hot to wear and of course on airplanes
and what have you and
there a long time ago i came up with a
test which is a lower the volume way
down to just
50 millivolts instead of 204 volts or or
more than the headphone output can
produce then i measure the signal noise
ratio so it's a very very difficult test
because you basically have such tiny
signal versus the residual signal
and uh if you look in here i've got it
i've tested it now on maybe i don't know
80 or 90 100
different headphone amps
and state of the art is about 95 94 db
and
the dx5 lands
around 90. 91 db we should be good
enough for almost every sensitive iem
and best ears out there
but obviously perfection is way out here
so
if you have an iem and that's extremely
sensitive and you're young and your high
frequency hearing is really good
you want to stay in this region and you
definitely want to avoid all of this
here these will produce audible hits and
noise in this region uh it's not like my
other cyanide deck where i said well
anything from here on is good uh you
know with iems you got to be careful uh
you basically have this transducer
stuffed all the way in your ear canal
and if it's sensitive boy it'll pick up
uh
you know and chance with noise like you
wouldn't believe at extremely low levels
becomes audible so uh they're much more
critical devices than
larger headphones are and certainly
speakers are
but after that we care about how much
power we get without distortion and how
much noise again we have and on this
thing and
in this test with 300 ohm load which
represents higher impedance low uh
headphones like sennheiser's um we get
237 milliwatts of power i like to see a
100 milliwatt once you get the 100 you
have plenty of power so this is two and
a half times more power which means that
you can drive any any high impedance
headphone to
air
bleeding levels and you can also then
drive 600 ohm once you get half the
power but there's still plenty
look at how much better it does than the
x3 pro it's got a nice wide gap low gain
is down here this is what it used to do
so and it just does not distort at all
as the x3 pro started to distort a
little bit
and the high gain mode uh goes way down
here and again no sign of distortion
whereas that the x3 pro was starting to
uh
turn up um a lot of times people ask me
how do you tell the distortion between
headphones and headphone amp you know if
it crackles and buzzes or whatever
you're hearing how do you know the
difference well you can learn it because
the distortions are very different but
if you haven't learned it one way to
tell is to get a headphone amp like this
that base has no distortion it never
clips at 300 ohm which means that it has
no distortion of its own so if you turn
it up this level
to max
stood just for a second or two don't
keep it there
if you're hearing crackling buzzing
popping any of those noises those are
all
headphone problems it has nothing to do
with the headphone amp and uh in a way
that's a good test to know if you have
enough power
you want the amplifier to be more
powerful than your headphone because
that way it'll it'll never be the
limitation
when amplifiers reach their limit as you
can see here distortion shoots through
the roof uh here's a test at 33 ohm and
so the moment you operate a headphone
amp in this level the dwarf the
distortion that headphones can generate
even though you think a mechanical
device can
is very distorted not the case when the
electronic amplifier goes into clipping
because this curve is just so steep it
just goes from
superb transparency to god awful so you
want to operate a headphone amplifier in
this region and you don't ever want to
go there um thankfully even with 32 ohm
load we have almost 2 watts of power
it's not insane amount of power you can
get more powerful headphone amps that go
3 4 watts
but it's certainly playing
fine for 95 percent of the headphones
out there and listening preference
on this thing so
if at all you can
you know get the most powerful one you
can
look at the impedance of your headphone
in my reviews and the company specs for
headphones tends to be accurate for
impedance or good enough and categorize
what class they're in are they high
impedance ones and high impedance i
would say anything from 150 ohm and up
to 600 or whatever and there's a large
cluster of headphones around 250 300
ohms or they go down in this class where
they're at or below this impedance a lot
of planar magnetic ones have very low
impedance and
so then this becomes representative and
that's why i test at these two extremes
there are crazy headphones that go even
lower
um down to you know 16 ohm 12 ohms even
so i measure the performance from 600
ohms down to 12. so for each one of
those there's a line in here
unfortunately audio precision software
won't let me express this as wattage it
only lets me measure the voltage
but wattage is v squared divided by r
so uh go ahead and square
you know the number on this graph before
you get clipping so for example on on
this one uh i forget what color this is
uh probably is the 12 yeah that's a 12
ohm one so at 12 on one we're getting
almost three volts so it's three volts
times three volts nine divided by twelve
you get a little bit less than a watt at
12 volts um if you look in here you'll
see that the uh
basically at 600 and 300 ohm there's no
clipping which is what i explained
earlier which means there's no
distortion completely transparent but as
soon as we get down to uh
50 ohm and below we start to get uh
these lines that shoot up through the
roof and again you can grab the voltage
over here and do the wattage formula and
know how much power you have
the key thing is that before clipping uh
none of these curves vary from each
other which means that the headphone amp
doesn't care about
the load at all it's fully independent
ignore these little glitches those are
measurement errors and pay attention to
this point when it doesn't move
between the loads it means that the
output impedance is extremely low so as
a switch loads there's no voltage loss
so anyway bottom line is extremely good
headphone amplifier very very
transparent transparent and very
powerful although not insanely powerful
it just is more powerful than 99
of what's out there
um i always perform listening tests
whenever there's a headphone amplifier
and what i listen for is actually the
effect of this i want to know in my
normal listening with difficult tracks
um whether i can get the amplifier to
distort and when it distorts what does
it do
some amps mute for example some amounts
get muddy some of them have this more
gradual rise in distortion
so i always do that listening test it's
easier to know for sure that there's
distortion with my ears than there is
with instrumentation
you know instrumentation sometimes hard
to
interpret so i start with my uh
one of the most
common headphones which is sennheiser hd
650 uh classic headphone million solder
worldwide
300 ohm
reason average sensitivity
so it needs some power it's not going to
sound good hooked up directly to your
phone
and
with this there was just incredible
fidelity and by the way i keep
forgetting how good the hd650 sound till
i put them on and just for testing and
it's like wow this takes really good
sounding headphone and i could crank
that volume up and at -10 db was already
pretty loud but for a second or two i
got it up to zero db
and i could tell you know my earlobe's
vibrating and my skull vibrating so
which of course not recommended um so it
has no trouble giving you incredibly
super fidel there's really a function of
how good your music is at that point as
the device is stepping out of the way
and delivering whatever level dynamics
you want so super super good now i don't
usually use my dan clark ones that you
see in here
my everyday headphones to test headphone
apps but it is
extremely insensitive it's like top five
most insensitive headphones i've tested
and um and it's low impedance i forget
what it is 25 ohm or something so it's
doubly hard on on a headphone amp and i
was pleased that i could get very good
volume out of them and to a point where
i was uncomfortable listening to at at
um close to zero db volume which is max
output of the dx5 uh on more powerful
amplifiers i can make these rat on my
skull too
but so it didn't go there but again it's
not safe listening uh so
you know even with the headphones it's
difficult to drive like the uh stealth
um you know it was more than usable and
fantastic sounding so uh i don't have
any concern that you're going to go buy
this and plug in a headphone say oh it
doesn't get loud enough it's not dynamic
enough not detailed enough well it is
all of that i don't care what what
headphone you can hook up to it
but you could do better and that's what
more expensive products exist
as far as headphone amps from topping
and others that just have a little bit
more power like topping a90
so what's the conclusion uh
we get incredible perfection as far as
noise and distortion
from topping as we expect but then we
have that ess imd hump which i didn't
expect
the jitter from toslink um if the
firmware update is coming to fix the ess
i'm the hump
then we're golden but even if it doesn't
again the distortion is incredibly low
uh it's just a visual problem of us
looking at the measurement saying hey
you know it could be better uh on this
thing so i'm going to recommend that um
the design industrial design is uh
um
it's something you have to decide if you
like it like it's very different than
the older products all the products were
more conservative this is a more
aggressive design going new direction
so
i haven't decided if i like it or don't
like it but i know i like the feel of
that volume control on the large display
which is more important to me than what
it looks like sitting at my
okay that's all i have for you on this
review and uh hopefully you learned
something and
and if you're in the market for a
combination dac and headphone lamp that
can drive your monitors on your desk and
let you listen at the same time which is
my category of device that i like uh on
my desk i want to test and drive
speakers and headphones and there's a
remote control by the way you can switch
which one turns on
and that's what you want to have on your
desk this kind of combination is great
with the largest display you can also
put in your main system
stereo system and control remotely in
that case i don't know if you use the
headphone amp but the dac itself is just
world-class
deck
okay i'll see you in a future video bye